ospvm les plaintes pour vol de véhicule
ont presque doublé en deux ans seulement
et un côté stratégique d'enquête mais il
y a un côté aussi comme je vous disais
des citoyens doivent vraiment se
responsabiliser au niveau des certains
outils qu'on peut aller chercher en
terme de localisation de véhicule
dans la chaîne de production chez
repérage tag personne ne change pour
fabriquer en grande quantité se traceur
de voiture unique inventée et développer
au Québec il a été conçu pour contrer le
vol de voiture nous on fonctionne avec
un autre système qui est à l'abri des
brouilleurs d'ondes et à l'abri des
toutes complications vis-à-vis
cellulaire au GPS vis-à-vis Leval auto
les assureurs cherchent avec ce type de
traceur à éviter qu'il le franchissent
la porte de sortie vers l'étranger ici
au port de Montréal en plein cœur de la
métropole les véhicules volés au Québec
sont exportés partout dans le monde afin
d'être revendu surtout vers des pays en
voie de développement un véhicule qui
coûte 50 000 au Québec dans les pays
choisis va valoir le double de son prix
en iOS Louise Gagnon qui s'est fait
voler son Honda CR-V à Dorval en octobre
2021 a retrouvé son véhicule au port de
Montréal prêt à partir à l'étranger
véhicule et puis mon véhicule avait
beaucoup de dommages j'ai appris une
semaine et demi pour qu'il que la police
c'est les assurances fassent leur
investigation
au final le vol des véhicules finit par
toucher le portefeuille de tous les
automobilistes tout le monde pense que
les assureurs vont payer
le véhicule qui a été volé mais en
réalité ce sont les contribuables qui
payent 10% de notre prime d'assurance va
à payer le vol d'auto de tout le monde
la direction du port de Montréal a
refusé de commenter la situation dans
ses installations ici Pascal Robida
Radio-Canada Montréal